[Musique]
J'aimerais que chacun de vous se lève et
nous raconte une histoire de cinq minutes sur votre été
[Musique]
à un moment donné vous feriez un choix sur
qui vous êtes et ce que vous voulez
[Musique]
jambon Roux I  Je suis accro ici à propos du
début d'un nouveau chapitre, une nouvelle fille en
ville et je pense que tu vas être ami
avec je suis réel et Jules, tout à coup, le
monde entier s'assombrit,
rien d'autre n'a d'importance sauf la personne qui se
tient devant toi
Je suis jaloux de votre génération, vous
ne vous souciez pas autant des règles, eh bien,
ils recherchent simplement quelque chose pour
que tout cela ait un sens
[Musique]
Chaque fois que je me sens bien, je pense
que ça durera toujours  rien ne
dure éternellement
j'ai une idée si je devrais
m'inquiéter de quoi que ce soit parce que je suis allé en cure de désintoxication, c'est la même
chose pour
moi ce n'est pas le point
si je pouvais être une personne différente,
je
bébé prends juste ton temps tu es délicat
maintenant  c'est tout le monde que j'aime pour au moins essayer
de changer
[Musique]
toi